because we have one more guest the the
oh okay the huge guest that we have yeah
so over the course of a hundred episodes
we have non-stop talked about George and
apologies for Jessica for Jessica and I
think in cotton because we've after 100
episodes I think it's time we tie some
loose ends and we have some closure
regarding George and Jessica so if we
can please welcome my best friend
Jessica yeah yeah yeah Roxette let it
play for a second
oh my god I love that song so much as a
Jessica welcome on the swamp
happy to you happy to you what I wanted
to say to you is first of all you're the
most Korean person I've ever met in my
life
I don't think so no in just in terms of
how I feel what does that even mean
because sometimes I want to headbutt out
of the face but that's the Korean hello
right there's not there is a physical
like I want to hurt each other yeah we
see you're also the most Korean person I
know why because I want a headbutt that
we got that established and number two
yeah and you you would you rejected you
rejected picnic you know from the very
beginning like tell me this what this
whole started I love uncomfortable isn't
it is is this for me to talk now is this
when did you first start and start when
do you just start to like Jessica when
did you meet her I met her just why
would I met her where I feel I'm feeling
like warm in my chest
you're fine
what's that if one of the fight one of
the fight nights here your memories are
burning a [ __ ] hole in her heart
I don't remember the first time meeting
her I remember yeah I think she helped
me do my hair one night podcast and I
think that you actually were very like
uninterested at that time
okay probably yeah yeah I feel so bad
for you right now
oh my right away George Gilbert first
Gilbert first Gilbert you want to eat
her ass or something we just wanted
strictly eating them yeah I guess yeah I
had heard about her beforehand from all
the Gilbert podcast yeah wanted to eat
her but yeah when I look at her I went
ahead better on the face I don't want to
eat or buy the story or the story yeah
yeah
journalistic yeah so George when did you
start feeling feelings no we were
hanging out like we were hanging out his
friends late for a while like who the
pot no no I I was like the thing is I
thought I was catching the vibe early on
but I wasn't sure I was really so I
didn't know so like because like I was
helping her out with like a few like
work things and stuff like being nice
and I was like and you were very helpful
I was like so she invited me out to
dinner and I was like yeah yeah yeah
that's what I put it I was still always
like what does this mean it's probably
just dinner as friends but it got the
like idea in my head I was like and then
we did dinner I was like yeah this was
as friends um oh yeah we still kept on
hanging out a little bit and then when I
don't like going on hikes and stuff oh I
enjoy hikes though there's not a fighter
you went hiking you and Hank did we did
we did yeah
what are you tonight what do you what is
your face saying right now no I want you
to finish your story and then
yeah well I've seemed like it seems like
everything I'm saying is wrong according
to your face don't look at me my friend
all right okay no no Jessica don't run
the [ __ ] gambit right I got it
look at me right now how are you feeling
now
so you're you go on hikes with her you
to dinner a kind of made you go oh maybe
one hike okay the one was with goby oh
yeah that's right because I needed like
another person yeah right so then when
you went on that way like more times
than just that oh yeah you guys also
went to San Diego together yes which you
were supposed to go to oh that's right
okay let's skip ahead let's skip ahead
we're hanging out as a group like a
group setting in a group setting yeah
then the weekend before San Diego mia
kalila and Gilbert were in here and
kalila asks this question like hey hey
who uh if Samba some girl just like
texted you out of the blue um like hey
you want to hook up just to check uh
check things out would you say yes and
like the the person in my head like when
I like when you said this I was like the
person who would do that
probably not somebody I would want to
hook up with I didn't have a face so I
would like kill innocent me and not
thinking like yeah kalila has no uh no
other reason to say this than just uh
because she's curious about texting
somebody every time yeah I was so I was
like gave an honest answer like no no
way that's weird and then I stepped out
of the house I was like one step out of
the house I was like wait a second that
was Jessica I would probably have said
yes and then I was like was it Jessica
do you think that I was asking on behalf
of her baby
you [ __ ] up as soon as I stepped out
of the house I did yo you did that I
don't want to the seed yeah as soon as I
did that yo but Kyle I did it but I
asked
what kind of medieval [ __ ] diet
[ __ ] here here's that here's what I
think okay in the very beginning I met
George I really do respect him so much
and of course if I yeah and I wanted to
uh if if I had ever are you laughing
I honest I did sort of entertain the
idea of the both of them possibly
hooking up because they're both people
that I really like and I wouldn't just
throw her to somebody that I didn't like
like I knew that George was like decent
and he was kind and he you know had you
know all of these things so yeah maybe
sometimes I through Georgia bond you
know so so I was like but I was like I
never caught like I was like never got a
sense from her like that there was any
possibility of anything so then the next
weekend you ditched out on San Diego
going to see sharks yeah I went but I
was like was that question was that
hypothetical for me I was like I have to
man up and just figure out now so then
because it because she asked that
question
mm-hmm and it led to the seed yes it
started growing inside your soul yes and
then you began to have feelings based on
this kind of little fantasy of maybe I
think yeah yeah so kalila did that so a
week of the the plant growing within
your soul then you go to San Diego which
was the cement the foundation I think
that built the house but you know what
the house was built on sand quicksand
hey thank you thank you thank you Jenna
quit sent the quicksand as I would soon
find out whether you go to San Diego
with her yeah and then what did you guys
do we went we went and swam with sharks
what a bonding experience yeah just you
and Jessica well what are you going to
San Diego with a guy for that you're not
you're not feeling you have any feelings
for I said I have a very deep love for
sharks mine yeah to kalila was supposed
to come I bailed that morning I know it
was left to George I'd be like I'm sick
by myself and I was going to go by
myself but he's like oh what's this
about you know this shark scene yeah
like well I'm going anyway you can come
if you want if that's how you said it I
you can look at the text while you saved
it you can look at the Kim Kardashian
over here cameras right so then you put
bait bait by her letting you go to San
Diego you kind of in your head famous
like I've because I feel like I'm kind
of being attacked here but like a claim
that somebody likes me is that is that
an insult don't insult me by saying I'm
from a woman's perspective it hears I'll
tell you how it is yeah
when when we have to deny some but not
deny or but like reject somebody and
it's especially if it's someone that we
actually like who's in our friend circle
it becomes very tricky because no matter
what we're the [ __ ] we're the enemy and
we're the ones who hurt you so for for
that whole feeling of feeling attacked
is it's something I'm very very familiar
with so because everybody even though we
make fun of you George we do like all
poor George poor George poor George when
it's really like she's more like why
poor George I I didn't do anything we
never had sex we never made out we never
did anything I don't she doesn't see no
I don't like no cast any blame yeah but
here's where she went wrong though you
don't invite a guy a single guy to San
Diego
why not because of the fact that he
might it wasn't everybody know she every
guy with a woman right wants to [ __ ] the
woman all right all right I'll go meet
I'll go meet um a girlfriend friend at a
coffee shop because they're going
through something whatever I'll do that
but if I was single but if I'm gonna go
on the road like not do stand-up but if
a girl went I'm going to El Paso just
for the weekend do you want to go
I already assume that their sexuality
going on I don't think George saw
every guy feels that way so you know
this no he didn't feel that way ask him
now he didn't feel that way well and so
when you you you're saying because you
planted the seed right a week before
because the seed right so the seed is
there so yeah seed not you're blaming
kalila for asking you a question that
probably might have buddy but be related
the seed has to land on fertile soil for
a grow so dope so you are for all right
so you went really as like oh I'm gonna
enjoy this time with a girl who's
friendly you didn't think like Oh Saxon
like no but I liked her he liked her
yeah okay no imagine he liked her he had
feelings I don't think at that point yes
he did you not listening baby at this
point I was like I have to see if they
if I have feelings or not I have to see
if something's there yeah but when
you're going to San Diego whether you
got excited not because you're the shark
hunting or whatever you guys are doing
right whatever you do with the sharks
right swimming with sharks but you are
excited because you're going to San
Diego with a girl that you might like
look at me right now yeah there you go
thank you what the [ __ ] are you having a
die going to San Diego with you I'm
going with or without him I know but
that's what you should have a Korean you
know you should have said no I'm going
on my own
Kyle that's not going I'm not gonna go
down sending with you I don't know you
because I I don't for me if I'm single
and there was a girl that I'm not
attracted to who was just a friend of
mine it was like I want to go with you I
would just be like okay why is it
alright yeah why is it always the woman
like why can't we is it's always on us
when we accept some type of invitation
my responsibility if I'm just like yeah
you know what I want to go with this do
it I don't know if I'm interested or not
but what's the what's the heard of that
I love how all the guys in this room
right now
it's
all the men in this room should be very
ashamed of yourself is that okay
if I was in the movie 300 no one would
show up okay we would be called one yeah
can I also ask you a question yeah let's
suppose even at that point in time even
if she had two percent of interest in
George and she wanted to explore it and
it may be after San Diego or maybe a
week after that she's like you know what
I thought I did but I didn't want to
that's also okay so even at that moment
I think that there was a little bit of
interest there initially because I do
honestly I do have like a tremendous
amount of respect for you and I felt
like no it's true I was in a very kind
of maybe like a challenging situation at
that time and I felt like you really
really you came through for her you did
and I was like whoa and it did make me
consider like he would be a clutch as
partner like in life because he was just
and you had advice that he was giving
was really um it's really rare to find
someone that can give advice outside of
themselves like only people can only
think like in their own perspective mhm
and he I think has this unique kind of
ability to really know yours anyways but
I I still think he's great and he's okay
whatever
and not to say that like and he's easy
to be around it's not like oh let me
take him to San Diego and rural or lat
tea is master know in heard of it I had
tried I had invited her to other things
like other social events like and like
she had always said no so this will hey
I wanted to say this right now and so
that you [ __ ] you [ __ ] weasel you
[ __ ] worm alright you go down to San
Diego with this one
alright you now you're sending your
feelings right a little bit that's when
you throw a move oh that's true we gotta
get right that's when you throw a
[ __ ] move nothing to me right right
and if she goes no you never talk to her
again no you see a high and events and
you go you know you can go ahead you
know
but in terms of you know you've distance
but that's not what you did oh no I did
no worse but well I made the move down
there then that's an awkward car ride
back that's true that's the price we pay
for taking risks okay so how did it go
down how did it get awkward at the end
though didn't it it did get big away no
no what happened was you came onto pod
cat he comes on the podcast he talks
about after San Diego I'm like with a
whole Drive back I'm like it's like I'm
in high school again I'm like come on
George man up just say something and see
if there's anything there and there's
the whole time yeah and then finally
just like she drops me like parks in
front of my house when you said it it
started I was like downtown LA okay ten
minutes to my house let's start the
conversation and then adjust weõve in
and out and I know I how I hate myself
so she go you said something what'd you
say what did you say yes oh geez what
did you say George you know this is okay
this is another issue what the [ __ ] did
I say okay no there was another girl who
would like the night before so I was
like let's let's be manly let her know
that I have other options
oh that's where you
when you'd like but it came out of my
mouth so weak I was like you idiot
I was like yeah so this last night this
other girl like she she wanted to date
me but I might have feelings for you so
like it was so high so he basically told
her there's this other girl that's
waiting so if you don't give it to me
I'm gonna go with the other girl yeah
Jesus George Wow George and so we do
that you the next we yell at you on a
podcast and that's that's when it hurt
because she knew no the next week the
next week like that had like she was
like Jessica like that it's after said
yeah she was like let me think about it
like good things to you doesn't want to
like hurt take me down so hard right
then I'm down right there than that so
so I'm like okay this is inevitable this
is gonna happen and I'm just like
cruising through that week then the next
week like that okay she rejected me on
the like the week after okay right
before the podcast then the podcast
comes and Bobby's like so you told her
about another girl huh and I was like
wait a second
Jessica talks to kalila kalila talks to
Bobby that's right I can have you know
of that I don't tell my friends anything
what yeah they're white their wife
Georgia's an analogy for me in the car
when I was driving him back home he was
like how are things with Jessica well if
you think of it like a stove I was like
and I smile I smile look at it tell me
about the stove
I put her on the burner I'm pretty high
I lowered it and you're like it had some
medium and then I think she might have
lowered the burner a little lower
though the day after okay I was gonna
call you out for like making that up
from Prairie Home Companion but no I
guess that's so then that was probably
my lowest point on Tiger belly is like
to realize like the grapevine because
I'm like if I say anything to Jessica it
can get to Bobby and hurt me oh if I
could say anything to anybody it'll get
the bike because I all admit a lot more
things to a lot more people than to you
Bobby I'm not gonna like give you any
ammunition you don't need me but I want
to let's so at this point Bobby on the
podcast you said George you need to man
up and make a move right told you he
gave you also the very wrong advice
which is what what advice also did you
give him kalila I don't remember oh I
think I might have I might have told him
to be more assertive no you did it what
did I did you said you said like come
like Oh pump the brakes a little yeah he
said to be assertive and just go for it
I said pump the brakes and you guys
Bobby
guys listen to me right now and do you
part I do pump thick brakes or do you go
for it he went for it let me ask you
something guys in the room completely
exactly but she's your best friend I
know exactly go for even if her best
friend is like a pump the brakes guys
you should have listened to the best
friend yes but I knew he doesn't know no
no with my psychology because at this
point he talked about it at this point
like if I hadn't made a move I was like
would have been waiting on her I
couldn't like Dayton Eli go try to date
any other girls cuz I would like it in
the back of my mind I was like if
Jessica even says like gives me
hint of anything I'll go with her I
can't like promise like anything to any
other women at that moment so I was like
okay I don't think Bobby's right here
but but I'm gonna listen to that advice
because I have to know for sure but that
would didn't change my psychology how'd
you do it George how'd you go away yeah
walk us to the disaster here so you're
at a stove right you're at the stove
you have the pan out you put the grease
in the pan I relive every other moment
and this one was still blocked from my
Merrill all right so tell me what
happened well that wasn't on purpose
okay so you're a little drunk
that was actually inadvertent hanging
out with Bryce Bryce yeah we probably
had these words are ringing in your head
go for it they would go for I think you
made fun of him like a lot yeah I still
do and I'll never stop no no the drink
it like the drinkin was a completely
inadvertent because I was like I texted
you earlier about like a could I drop
off some bags because I which I don't
receive anymore his dick you get eggs
like I was like wait until she was home
with like ten or something so like Bryce
and I really like to do we were out
drinking at shortstop and then I Drive
over any extra bar I love it a suit like
yeah I'm like driving there and I'm like
I am a little drunk this is gonna look
well bad but I was like nah I can
pretend to not be drunk I can do that so
yeah again I made up we chatted for a
little bit and you're at the house you
just text you like you home yeah and you
didn't tell me it was coming then he
just shows up at the door
did you bags oh I would beg to differ
with the textual exchange on this one
and or not it matter it matter
no he just came like to the door with
eggs or not the eggs matter guys let's
just let's just go with eggs that's sad
you didn't have eggs when you're drunk
and 10:00 p.m. or whatever time it was
he always shows up with it yeah okay
you're at the house right you're drunk
and then tell me walk me through what
happens we're chatting she goes outside
we walk to like her car she'd like get
something from her car or something and
I'm like annoyingly close and then like
guys we sit down on a curb or something
and she's just like giving me nothing
absolutely nothing and I'm like well you
know what if I tried to kiss her right
now she would like really like that I'm
sure and that's what I was missing out
on like you know like voice in your head
I was like what happened is she didn't
get to kiss me so that's why she
rejected me earlier if she had that
opportunity things would be so different
and then I leaned in like my breath
reeking of beer and just got soundly
rejected with like a why are you doing
that what what are you doing you said
that Jess talk into the mic Jess I
wouldn't be surprised if that's what I
said because as he said I was giving him
nothing and I didn't know that this was
going through your head but he was
sitting there he was a little close and
I was like mm maybe he's he's trying and
I don't know but we were just sitting
like next Sujit side-by-side yeah and
all of a sudden and I think I see his
arm come around like like this and and
he kind of
like he rushed me a little bit she
didn't want to miss me oh you didn't
miss move yeah and then you said what
are you doing and then what'd you say
yeah that's what I said
I don't remember I've locked the rest of
this from my memory I do I can't believe
you didn't kill yourself oh my god that
I wouldn't be able to live through that
that's what makes you a man a man no I
was like very it's very interesting I'd
like to wrap this up with you yeah
hard-hitting questions here yeah Jessica
from the bottom of your heart the Mo's
your and most honest I considered it
yeah did you consider I can hetero sex
with him Oh Caleb one to ten ten being
the most consideration and zero being no
considering consideration is just yes or
no George Kimmel for your consideration
not even on my nominees did you wonder
about excise
yeah but I'm curious about everybody
that's true okay and so after the
rejection you went home woke up the next
day and you knew was done and then I
watched Breaking Bad for a week straight
and I finally caught up on Breaking Bad
how depressed three you for a week
pretty damn depressed okay one final
question before we wrap this up guys Ari
it's not your fault it's no one's fault
one final question George do you yeah I
got to finish Breaking Bad you know I
hadn't finished it before I needed to be
depressed to be doing this final
question when you see her around now do
you still have lingering feelings it's
as simple as yes or no George oh no
no no just say no no okay oh my god
questions you ever considered me a
little bit just go look at me for real
no Gilbert I love you I love you
[Music]